what up reject nation we're gonna watch
brooklyn nine-nine as always hit that
like button if you end up enjoying our
reaction from the dislike button it
doesn't matter which one be sure to
subscribe and click that bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next
one is up and you know full length watch
along so you're syncing with the
timecode for b99 or over at our patreon
page you know the gist
gotta be careful on how to pronounce
that or else youtube's gonna be like
what you say
what yellow dollar
all right guys let's get into it people
[Music]
all right gang died day four how's
everyone holding up honestly i'm going
to last forever you hear that [ __ ]
i'm gonna laugh last forever
this morning the homeless guy in my
stoop said my skin looked dope
we're doing a diet together my wife
found it she heard about it at mommy and
me graphic design wait it might have
been tyler karate
she takes our little ladies to so many
classes i can't keep it straight
childhood is truly a time of wonder
all the meals are pre-planned and
delivered to your doorstep this is our
breakfast an orange wedge three cashew
nuts and a solitary grate
we're gonna get through this together
hey guys pro tip
lick the baggie there's food molecules
in there oh that's so
smart i do that sometimes
[Music]
i'm here to meet charles did you hear
what he did last night
drank it jake
why is there a bow tie in here best man
jake peralta will you be my best man
plus he gave me this to prep
fancy broad gum it means fancy groom and
danish according to charles the danes
throw the most beautiful weddings in the
world and the most violent funerals
hello my big beautiful bm best man just
best man
totally prepared i even bought some
nurse shoes love them mm-hmm
officer deepmore helped me out with my
crime scene so i gave him a little thank
you present you're gonna bag evidence
like a five-year-old you should have the
proper tools
it's my first police kit
you humiliated officer deepmore in front
of his peers he submitted an official
complaint against oh no
he did lose a green pen which seems
crazy to me
[Laughter]
i'm great at apologizing i'm a very
sweet person
out of my weight chunk
[Laughter]
the engaged life is amazing especially
sexually well i don't want to cry you're
not crying i want you to know this
[Laughter]
oh i'm usually more of a chocolate guy
but this one's closer so i'm going to do
that
it's habanero pepper frosting because
our marriage is going to say all
right come on show me what you got
awesome
liberace diane keaton roger that
summer linen suit casual but classic
actually not bad one question pink tie
can you see my underwear oh yeah why are
you wearing a thong it's why something
borrowed
lunch time wait's over that was easy
totally i feel like we just had our
snack an hour and 17 minutes ago
[Laughter]
though i did take diet pills in the 70s
i love these pills they give me so much
energy
and i can eat whatever i want
oh god
oh
he's dead
[Laughter]
ingredients
carrot you got to respect that
i knew it
sloppy jessica mac and cheese chili
pizza on a bun
oh my god
oh my heart hurts oh my god and i want
it too i thought you were gonna last
forever [ __ ] turns out i gave up easy
you hear that [ __ ] i gave up so easy
own it girl do you have a penalty bar to
sign these forms you bet i don't have a
pen i never do
[Laughter]
oh no it's my retirement paperwork what
shut up what yeah vivian got a job in
suburban ottawa she wants me to retire
from the nypd and go with her no
boyle we're supposed to die on the force
together me and a big explosion and you
committing suicide at my funeral out of
respect
yes
it has everything brooklyn does really
yes
other than my job and my friends my
family
you every other reason that i have to
live okay i'm kind of picking up on a
couple of clues but you maybe don't want
to retire in canada oh my god jake
you're such an amazing detective i don't
want to go
a plus
vivian i love you but we need to talk
about ottawa right and then she'll say
you're a selfish man pig and i hope you
die alone and i never loved you
going to the stationary store next we
can write a bunch of stuff down it's
going to be all right take a deep breath
no deep breaths
makes the testicles clap
it's like every fitting i've ever had
i've been working on a letter to send
him yes that's our draft of it on your
desk what do you think it was so
horrifying i had to destroy the whole
pad
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry it's like an acting
exercise yeah
i'm so good that's the one
[Laughter]
nailed it i've been sucking on it so
long it's smooth it's like sea glass you
do you
no
i'll get that for you ames
the cashew no
butter feed sorry about that sorry
you bumbling son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i hope you get hit by a truck and a dog
on your face
i'm never like that that's okay it's my
fault i shouldn't bump your cashew
cashew it was an almond you idiot i hope
you drown in a tub
i'm gonna go talk to vivi great idea
buddy
huh yep oh
you can't tempt me traitor
not when i got this big juicy cantaloupe
wedge to keep me company it's so thin i
could see through it
come hold this so it looks bigger in
your tiny hand
santiago loves cantaloupe time we wrote
a song about it
cantaloupe
cantaloupe
that was so funny this is my second
burger
okay i lied it's my fourth
yeah but you didn't mean it i'd like you
to apologize like you mean it
fine
oh no oh
i'm sorry you screwed up my case
i'm sorry you're a terrible cop i'm
sorry for your goat face and your rodent
brain and your weird goose body and then
all of that
i sat down face to face
then i panicked and totally bailed i
don't know the good news is she's on her
way here and you're going to talk to her
for me oh no just tell her i absolutely
shouldn't return move to canada but
don't tell her i think that
oh
no
[Laughter]
i tried talking to her just like we
practiced but every time i bring up
ottawa she says how excited she is about
her future then we made love don't say
made love fine we had wonder sex don't
want to know what that is
but i can't lose her you're my best man
please help me fine i'll try okay but
bring it up naturally so she doesn't
think i put you up to it sure how hard
could that be i'm constantly talking
about suburban ottawa
wait don't go
myself to be why would i stay for that
moral support please eat you look weak
i'm fine i am stronger than ever watch
this
oh no
what are you doing
what the [ __ ] wow
see i'm fine
what is happening oh
damn messed up my system
oh no
oh no
oh no terry no
go back inside
[Music]
where does the best maple syrup come
from again vermont
[Laughter]
canada hey that reminds me weren't the
two of you talking about maybe moving
there oh yeah we are so excited to start
this new chapter of our lives together
i wonder if that's the best thing for
him
it's so sweet of you to care but
chuck is excited about moving to canada
right baby
do they even have pizza in canada yes
it's puffier and it's sweet it's called
manitoba sauce cake okay there's no way
charles wants that i think you're
overstepping here
charles and i both want to move to
canada is that true charles is that what
you want
come on buddy
i want to retire from the force and move
to ottawa with vivian and frankly i have
no idea why you're getting involved
leaving
what
[Laughter]
when i was a young officer i was that
rat and got zapped
and all i wanted was to be captain and
throw some lightning bolts emperor
palpatine
[Laughter]
i think you're a leader what
that's [ __ ] i'm sorry please yes
no need to make a scene
charles get in the car no
go to heck let's get the lights hunt
police stop walking
oh i hate that i'm so buy the book
you're not handing in those retirement
papers without telling vivian how you
feel i won't let you oh really and how
are you gonna stop me baton to the knee
batons didn't he
ah
i'm sorry for making fun of you in front
of everybody
and also for making fun of you behind
your back
didn't know you did that but thank you
for the apology i'm not done also i'm
sorry for making fun of you during my
book
club also i'm sorry it's okay
i get it no
also i'm sorry that i didn't take the
time to show you how to fix your mistake
come on we can go over it upstairs
thanks that'd be great
one more sorry you're about to see a
drawing i did of you in the elevator
just remember i was really pissed to you
at the time
[Laughter]
i'm making you talk to vivian okay
thanks
you're right
and you know what
i'm ready
[Laughter]
why the long fart
my wife is on the diet she's a little
self-conscious about her body since
giving birth to twins it's crazy
i think she looks perfect and i tell her
that all the time oh and i love that you
do that terry
one thing i thought i could do here just
hand me that milkshake
oh hey what are you doing what
thank you we are still a team and we
will keep you from eating so you can
support your wife
however just to be clear gina and i are
still going to eat
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
dogs
hello vivian charles has something you'd
like to say
in case he tries to flee
we need to talk about ottawa
wow
vivian and i talked for hours there's a
lot more to discuss but it's a start you
were right she didn't dump me your
duties as best man aren't over yet what
whiskey and cigars
thanks for being the best best man to
the fancy brood gum
huh spicy why is that spicy
i could spend my time talking about how
good of an episode that is
so funny
enhance the characters all around
all i'm thinking about
is how
this [ __ ] hasn't done anything at all
from my wedding coming up
what do you want
wow
i've i've done some research on what
best men are supposed to do oh yeah okay
yeah whatever really
[Laughter]
yeah who has the big thing to do
you
i'm fighting for both of us
mostly i'm frightened that's not the
best man's physician the best man is
supposed to be like no we're gonna we're
gonna get we're gonna have so much fun
doing stuff you like yeah and we won't
have time yeah i know we'll just be here
be here today before be like hey greg i
got you a bachelor party
we're collabing with a couple people
while we continue to share
um well yeah it's a good episode it was
funny as hell that was really funny yeah
i know what it's like to go on those
crazy diets
they're not fun actually my friends tony
and courtney
um
they
have already done more for the wedding
than john has they
uh
used to do this diet they really lost a
bunch of weight
it was the stupidest dino they've ever
gone back to it again
or it was like you could only have five
bites a day
that oh that doesn't sound like it's
based on real science whatsoever yeah
it's like i lost a lot of weight i was
like no [ __ ] you lost a lot of weight no
matter how big those bites are you're
not eating much oh my god that sounds
awful it doesn't matter how much you
jam-packed your mouth
yeah uh
it's it's terrible seeing that he had
the digestive stuff your body wants to
clean itself out the second lifted it up
i was like i feel like i'd take a [ __ ]
right there
once with the weight going on and then
they start farting and they're like oh
that's
that's about accurate to the situation
at hand
uh but uh i've only done like a cleanse
like like cleanse twice in my life only
for like five days
nothing of that caliber where it's like
a fruit it's like
but you know whatever
it's not about that that's what you
should try next see i just love working
out but i love eating
well you need to eat
this stagnant part of my body
well you know right now i just want to
go to the kitchen eat some cheese it's
it's all i'm really thinking about
i haven't had cheese in a long time
cheetahs are amazing they're the best
they're baked and the delicious mm-hmm
that's what i learned from this episode
but also with uh uh
rosa rosa
rosa learning some real false leadership
crap no you're supposed to talk down all
the time especially
if you have a group of people that's how
you keep people moving that wheel
i'm afraid yeah you dangle the cheese on
the wheel and then if they're doing a
bad job you yell at all them that's how
you handle a collective of people i've
never understood how else you're
supposed to do it
i could learn a lot from from you
shut up john oh
that's great advice thank you
feels so much better prepared now
uh
no yeah that's true of
oh yeah i never really viewed rose's
leader but i once he said it i was like
oh yeah yeah i see the leadership i'll
see the leadership capabilities they're
all right there see the potential as
long as she can reign in some of her
more uh
outwardly abrasive tendencies yeah
reactionary tendencies you're definitely
a leader sean i am
and i've been waiting for you to
acknowledge
mr initiative over here
yup that's how you do it you just make
fun of john
that's right man
because i i have a confident idea of
what is the right thing to do always
act on it right away
you won't feel very dumb later for
attempting this
uh and then
what oh yeah of course the best man
stuff too yeah man
coming up with that you know uh uh
mustering up the courage to be honest
with your partner it's hard
never happens yeah because we're too
busy uh john's always initiating the
conversations
the tough talks oh he's going out there
that's right man i'm definitely more of
a peralta in this situation
yeah i mean you're more of a peralta
across the board yeah it's like with a
little bit of terry mixed in
terry yeah you know cause like you know
you get [ __ ] done and like you're good
at whipping people onto task you're like
if peralta's fun met terry's structure
you're not quite a whole cause you're
not that stuffed you know
i think i'm a little bit more of a holt
sure i mean holt and terry have similar
leadership attributes whoa racist that's
right because they're both buff
[Laughter]
uh yeah
yeah what the hell what do you want from
us this is
hopefully you got a few more laughs out
of the sitcom that happened after the
sitcom after the episode yeah man that's
uh
that was such an episode yeah man every
plot line had some fun juju in it you
can't force people to do something no
you can't change people but people can
change themselves
no matter how hard you try
you just can't seem to change people the
way you want to shape them yourself
it's hard
that's hard you know because i
constantly see people as like this this
clay
you know what i mean this play-doh
mm-hmm
then i'm just like let me go in there
and just do you
shape you the way i see you
my image yeah they say don't look at
people for who they are look at them for
who they can become
and i go yeah let me try to get them to
be who they can become
forcefully
[Laughter]
and you know it never not once has
panned out good for me let me outwardly
reject who they are
only focus on who they could be through
my own specific lens approach with
here's what's wrong with you
let me make you right here
yeah let me boil the snare the
circumstances of you and your existence
down to a binary of good or bad
that's all help that's how you do it
yeah
that doesn't screw anybody up uh yeah
this was uh this was awesome this is
another solid installment
all right guys
don't worry
we'll get two to two a week eventually
two days especially now the show's over
yeah dude we gotta ride that wave it
just ended up we're gonna ride that away
from no one watching get in here
all right come on get the nostalgia
waves next though we gotta yeah
maybe it'll take off these will pick up
in like ten years yeah ten years now
it's gonna be blowing
everyone's gonna be like remember
brooklyn nine-nine yeah yeah yeah well
eventually we we're in the long term
game so eventually the views on these
are going to skyrocket or you're going
to see a surge definitely and that's
going to be the number one thing on the
channel it's like when cobra kai moved
to netflix surge in views
yeah yeah and then instead of spider-man
all the time we'll just cover brooklyn
nine-nine all the time i freaking
peacock get more viewers peacock if you
get more viewers and subscriptions
more people will watch our videos or
just sell your crap to netflix yeah dude
everyone's got netflix
[Laughter]
damn streaming services
all right guys listen we're done with
today's video if you enjoyed john's
discussions points
subscribe to john's
youtube channel
called
the quartering
yeah that's that's me
no that's not you yeah i just strap on a
big beard
i just shave it off every time i come in
here i have a problem that grows very
fast
okay guys well we're about to do an
interview with alex jones
um but before we do that
rosa parra rosa considering that this
episode dealt significantly with a
latina
person who
found herself in a leadership
position today
obviously i'm going to think about you
you're someone who has a story that
inspired me because
you
were dealt a couple of shitty hands
and then what did you do you roasted the
occasion you see this
this is called an obstacle
this is you
and what did you do
you
overcame the obstacle
ensure did you land on your butt at one
point yeah but what did you do you got
off your butt onto your feet
climb the stairs
of parental and career success and
dreams
and now
here you are today forgetting that
you're still pledged to our patreon page
so rosa
i think what you're missing is a tad bit
more management skills if you're able to
go through your checking or credit card
account you'll see that oh i forgot to
cancel my subscription to their patreon
so long ago
so
um i'm here to help you out with that
just uh shoot me a message
and i can refund you for the last four
years
yeah this justin yeah greg is negative
in his bank account
oh bro
that's mean
but we love you anyway
sorry it broke now it's fine i don't
know why i didn't take it here
you know
be careful what you say during a patron
of the day shout out that's all i'm
saying
[Music]